poppy said the most beautiful thing she
said well mom
now he's out of that wheelchair and he's
running in heaven
jenna bush hager mourning the loss of
her beloved father-in-law
john hager who died sunday at 83
while chatting with today's show co-host
hoda copy on monday
jenna i got to hand it to you again
today i mean your father-in-law passed
away
and he passed away on sunday and you
walked in this morning
and you say good morning and you do what
you do and i thought you know a lot of
people have to put a brave face
on in life and you're doing that uh this
morning so
i am we lost my beloved father-in-law i
feel so lucky that he was mine
the 38-year-old tv personality went on
to pay tribute to her late
father-in-law's
tenacity despite being confined to a
wheelchair for almost
half his life he was diagnosed with
polio
45 years ago but he never let it stop
him i think he did 13 marathons in a
wheelchair
what's more john was the first person
with a disability
to serve as the lieutenant governor of
virginia
so the flags if you're in virginia are
you half mass for him
he just broke defied all expectations
wow
but more than that he was a beloved
husband and father and father-in-law
and grandfather he always played with
the kids
he was on their level you know he was
down and
his nickname his name as a grandpa was
bumpy
and the daughter of former president
george w bush
took a moment to empathize with anyone
else who's lost a loved one during the
global pandemic
i think that what we can do is remember
how precious these people are so we lost
him but he is still with us and
poppy said the most beautiful thing she
said well
mom now he's out of that wheelchair and
he's running in heaven
jenna also paid tribute to her husband
henry hager's late father on instagram
she shared these touching photos and
praised him in the caption
for being a giant of a man who was also
compassionate curious
and kind earlier this month the mom of
three opened up to et's rachel smith
about reuniting with family after
spending months in quarantine
to celebrate her son hal's first
birthday
it was so nice we all got cold be tested
we made sure that we just hung out with
each other um but to be able to be with
them after not seeing them for eight
months you realize what's really
important and it's family and friends
and that watching them hug and hold howe
who they had only really met a couple
times
because we've been in quarantine for
four months yeah
was really special
you